hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
we are officially
in a recession yesterday it was
announced
that we are officially in a recession
for the first time
in 11 years how do i feel about that
how should you feel about that well the
first thing i want to say is
this is not a big deal now
this my channel i guess is a media
outlet you could call it i put out
information on this channel
nearly every media outlet the newspapers
the tv
all they try and do is they try and get
views they try and
scare people because bad news and
fear-mongering
leads people to be excited because
people are addicted to bad news and
people want to be afraid and they love
bad news
whereas i want to actually just tell you
the truth and the truth is that there's
a recession
every 10 years typically every 10 to 15
years
there'll be a recession and after a
recession there'll be an expansion and
after an expansion there'll be a
recession
and that's always been the case as far
back as we can go
so this is not a big deal this is
nothing to be worried about however you
do need to be aware of it you need to
know what a recession means
and you need to pivot your business as
an entrepreneur and as someone who's
responsible for your finances
in order to succeed so first thing is
you need to know what a recession
actually is many people that are scared
of a recession
don't know what a recession is so if you
don't even know what it is how can you
be afraid of it many people that talk
about it don't know what it is so
this is a recession a recession is when
there's a general
decline in economic activity
that's what it means there's a general
decline in economic activity
basically in layman's terms that means
when
people aren't spending money now
normally when people aren't spending
money it's because they haven't got any
money then maybe there's vast
unemployment and there's no money going
around
or it could be the banks aren't giving
out money that can cause a recession
but in this instance the reason for the
recession is because
people aren't spending money because
they can't because
everything has been closed so over the
last two quarters
there's been a down turn in economic
spend
but how can people spend money when
they're not going out to restaurants
when they can't go to football stadiums
they can't go to concerts they can't
trade you can't meet people you're
locked down so
when when it's almost like it's a shock
we're in a recession it's like
yeah well of course we're in a recession
it's kind of obvious
that people aren't spending money and if
people aren't spending money if that's
what the definition of recession is
then yes of course it would have been
announced at some point that we
are in a recession it's also really
important to note
that just because there is a recession
right now and generally the economy is
doing badly
it isn't necessarily a bad time to start
a business and
not every business is struggling and
doing bad financially
some businesses right now are absolutely
flourishing
others have been hit and in a recession
and in a boom
that's when there's usually opportunity
people make money
and people lose money in a recession and
in
a boom so when things are going up and
when things are going down
generally within the economy that's the
time to do something and that's the time
to do something big
right now if you spoke to richard
branson he'd tell you he's struggling
right now
now on a personal level i'm sure he's
still doing extremely well but his
business is
all around things like travel holidays
planes trains where right now that isn't
really functioning that's not really a
thing so he's losing millions and
millions and millions of pounds
he's just sold millions and millions of
pounds worth of shares
of one of his businesses so right now
richard branson is going to be thinking
all right
i need to do something a little bit
different on the other hand some people
like jeff bezos is absolutely
rolling in it he's rolling in the deep
jeff actually had a divorce which cost
him 38
billion pounds just let that sink in
jeff lost
38 billion pounds now a million pounds
is a lot of money
a million a million a million a million
a million a thousand times
is a billion he lost 38
billion pounds when he got divorced
however since
the pandemic he's now made all that
money back
amazon is doing better than it's ever
done before because people
are ordering things online so for jeff's
business
it's a really good thing for richard
branson's business it's not a good thing
so what does that mean for you well what
that means for you is you want to think
okay well how can i in this
recession that we are officially in as
from yesterday
how can i do a business a service have a
product
that can flourish right now as opposed
to having it
go really bad now don't forget as well
that this lockdown that's happening
is we're coming out of the lockdown so
things are beginning to get back to
normal for a lot of businesses so it's
not to say oh my goodness
let's just only do online businesses and
let's close down our i'm running
i run an events business i have a
training company and over the last few
months my training company has been hit
really bad now some people think oh
boohoo samuel but
it's not about this isn't about me my
salary comes from my property business
i'm in the same boat
but my training business i've got staff
that need to be employed and some of
those staff their full-time job is to
go to events and do the lighting and the
sound and right now we're not running
events
so so my training business my events
business has been hit hard and then in
other areas to my business
some of my property business has got is
going exceedingly well
i've actually had to refinance some of
my properties
to pay wages for some of my staff it's
been a really crazy challenging time
but the thing is it's really important
to note that as an entrepreneur
you need to adapt you need to be fluid
that's part of being an entrepreneur so
when i hear words like recession
i get excited because i know that in a
recession and a boom
that's when people make most money i had
a friend around my house yesterday his
name's rory he was sat
in this chair where i'm sitting he's
making eight million pounds a year he's
got the largest
guttering business in the uk and he said
that profits have
never been as high as they are right now
in this
pandemic and lockdown so that's the
thing
how can you make how can you be on this
side rather than on this side
how can you rather rather than worrying
about the economy
how can you make sure that you have a
good economy because i really really
believe that we
create our own economy so you might be
thinking but samuel what about property
this is a property channel i'm a
property investor you're a property
investor
what about property so let me talk a
little bit about property right now
although we're in a recession house
prices are not
going down right now despite what the
media will tell you
the media lie with headlines they've
been putting headlines out in the
newspapers
property price is down four months in a
row
and it's like listen listen you read
this and you think oh my gosh property
price is down
okay so in a particular area and how
much down
four months in a row down oh 0.1 percent
come on media stop trying to scare
people with your headlines that's what
they do
last month across the uk house prices in
july actually were
up 1.6 percent
media they'll sell stories that try and
scare people
property prices are doing just fine now
i always say this though and i'm going
to say this again don't worry about what
property prices are going to do in the
next couple years because
when i started in property i started in
2008 i was buying in 2009 everyone was
saying terrible time to buy
i bought and guess what house prices
went down and everyone would have said
terrible terrible terrible
doesn't matter because i held on to the
properties and then they went up
so if you hot if you're buying a
property to hold on to it
it's not a bad time to buy right now
ultimately capital appreciation will
happen but it's also really important to
remember
that capital appreciation does not pay
the bills
so when you buy a house don't just buy
it and think about what's going to
happen in the next year or so
listen i can sit here all day long and
talk about predictions and what i think
is going to happen
and i can say right now london is going
to go
down liverpool is going to go
up that's going to happen that's my
opinion
but i don't want you to buy for that
reason i want you to buy
for cash flow i want you to buy for
return
on investment but i'll tell you
something it's important to do something
don't just sit there and rely on the
government and your employer
because right now jobs 730
000 people over this lockdown period
have been made redundant i believe that
there'll be over a million people
just from from a result of this this
pandemic that are going to lose
their jobs often with nothing
to go to which is why i think so
passionately it's important to not rely
on the government or on an employer but
to rely on yourself
and be an entrepreneur and make sure
that whether the market's going up
whether the market's going down you know
how to
make money richard branson right now yes
he's probably
a little bit stressed he's struggling
his businesses are really struggling he
might
lose some i think one of them even went
bankrupt in the us
one of his one of his virgin companies
but guess what richard branson
is gonna be okay don't worry about
richard branson i'll tell you one thing
he's gonna be fine why
because his blueprint is programmed for
success he's going to be just fine
don't worry about jeff don't worry about
me you need to worry about making sure
that
you are going to become successful and
going to become wealthy
through this pandemic through this
recession
if you want to see what i think what's
going to happen in the future the
predictions
over the next year or so then you can
check out this video right here
if you want to subscribe to this channel
you really should do that
then do that right here and guys please
do
smash the like button drop a comment and
let me know what you think thank you so
much for watching i'll see you next time